are likely entertaining for the holidays
so how do we pair our wines and our
cheeses have no fear the Wonder Woman of
cheese is here to help us look like
we're the experts welcome the owner of
Valley cheese and wine Diana Breyer well
hello nice to meet you you're so
knowledgeable and you always teach us
tricks and what I love the best about
you is you help us pair things that
honestly I probably wouldn't try or I
wouldn't buy a bottle of and then I
tried and I'm like wow I've been missing
out so you brought some great stuff
today yeah so usually during the holiday
season we talk about a lot of the more
classic traditional pairings you know we
talk about champagne and Brie we talk
about port wine and dessert cheeses and
things like that but what if you are a
little bit more adventurous what if
you're a little bit more playful with
your palette there are some really fun
Alternatives that we can do for Holiday
pairings that are sort of going to
emanate that classic you know element of
those wines and cheese pairings but just
in a totally different way and totally
fun and unique you take us out of our
comfort zone which is what we need and
then we find that we like more things so
there is no palette growth without
comfort discomfort ready let's talk
about this cheese here this looks like a
soft cheese here this is a soft cheese
what is it bubbly and soft cheese is
also a really good way to go so
essentially this is a marinated sheep
and goat milk cheese from Australia it's
marinated in olive oil peppercorn and
Thyme so it has this really beautiful
like texture it's really silky on the
mouth feel nice and tart but overly
fatty and beautiful nice herbaceous
undertones and then when you chase it
with this kava this is actually made in
a champagne method so Cava is made in
the same way champagne is but it's from
Spain has a little bit more earthy
characteristics a bit more
herbaceousness to it so if you try the
cheese and then Chase it with the Cava
you'll notice that that bubble sort of
sort of really dissipates that cheese
flavor onto the palette and just
proliferates with like it almost like
paints this beautiful picture upon your
little canvas how do you just discover
this that is insane we have a lot of fun
in the shop making these pairings like
when you pair these things together
honestly like separately great together
magical yeah that that was fabulous I'm
saving this because I want to finish
this this is so good and then I love I
love love love your palette but I also
know that you do have some Hungarian
roots and so I love to play around with
that with you specifically so we brought
a dessert wine A lot of people are used
to port wine for the holidays this is a
Hungarian dessert wine called Tokai so
this is a late Harvest Tokai out of
Hungary okay um you're gonna notice some
like baked apple characteristics to it
um some stone fruit it's got some honey
characteristics as well so it's a nice
way to introduce a dessert wine that
maybe isn't a port okay um so try that
out and see how that goes for you
because you're going to find a lot of
like like dried stone fruit baked apple
a little bit of lemon really just
beautiful it's easy it's light it's
delicate it's simple to drink so it's
not going to be too assertive on
somebody's palette who's not used to
dessert wine that was gosh your
descriptions are like magical it was
it's exactly that it's not super
assertive I liked it it was just nice
and smooth and what what do we pair this
with so this is actually with a super
rare gouda uh formerly called Black
Betty this is broadbander reserve it's a
goat milk gouda out of Holland has a
little bit of extra age on it so you're
going to get some brown butter
characteristics some floral notes nice
tyrosine Crystal little granularity of
texture on the palette add that Tokai
back in and it just sort of like plays
around beautifully together because that
brown butter characteristic of the gouda
is going to work with the baked apple so
you have this really sort of like almost
pastry like characteristic that comes
forward it just plays so well together
your pairings are Exquisite you can get
you can get the best advice from Diana
tell us where you are located if people
want to get some of this amazing product
sure I'm at Valley cheese and wine we
are in Henderson on Horizon Ridge uh in
the McDonald Ranch area we have a happy
hour we do gift baskets for the holidays
for corporate gifting we are doing a New
Year's Eve celebration so we have a lot
of fun stuff going on in the shop and
you can definitely experience these
pairings in person with us I'll teach
you all Hungarian toast eggs